Will Smith has always been one of my
favorite actors but he honestly has not
made a film since 7 pounds it's been a
long time seems like he's been working
on jump-starting his kids careers the
trailer came out today and I was pretty
excited because I had no idea it
actually came out today and I just saw
it I was like whoa it's out I'm gonna
watch this right now who are we we are
no one our mission is to monitor
extraterrestrial activity on earth I
love the first film the first film is
one of my favorite movies it's just such
a fun good movie that I grew up with
from a 90s it just reminds me of my
childhood the second film it was okay I
guess it just had some funny moments the
beatboxing scene is great now this
trailer I'm thinking a few things either
one it's not giving away that many jokes
which is good or the film isn't as funny
as I would like it to be but the thing
is it's just the first trailer and I
don't like when trails give away too
many jokes so I feel like they're
probably doing that here go you know
you're not supposed to be north of Canal
Street who is knuckle let's relax Punk
they're looking for me not too crazy
right two grown men talking to the wall
wall talking back it's a mess okay don't
even worry about it I knew what the plot
was I thought it was kind of interesting
and it could bring for a lot of comedy I
like Josh Brolin who's playing a young
version of Kate I love Tommy Lee Jones I
love Will Smith and it seems like they
still have their characters just intact
here there's also some cool-looking
practical effects in the trailer and I'm
always I'm all for practical effects CGI
gets old after a while practical effects
all the way okay I'm looking for K have
you seen him sort of a surly older
gentleman he smiles like this
okay he's been dead for over forty years
for the most part I'm satisfied with
this trailer I wasn't expecting it and
so it was just a nice surprise to see
something from the film I'm glad to see
Will Smith back I'm interested in seeing
where the movies gonna go
I'm skeptical a little but for the most
part I think he looks entertaining and
I'm excited to see men in black back and
I hope that it works out and that it's
more like the first film enlist like the
second so we'll see what happens
who knows
okay how do you know my name tonight I'm
gonna go see Sherlock Holmes - and I'll
let you know what I think after that